nice little Street with nice people when
I first moved here I was made to feel
very welcomed by all my neighbors but
after coronavirus I thought I'd take the
opportunity to see how my neighbors are
and make sure that nobody's feeling
isolated so what I did was I wrote a
letter and I sent it out to every house
on my street we had so many people from
across the street who joined the Watts
up group and it's been amazing today I
sent a message to the neighborhood group
and asked them if they wanted me to do
anything for them and now I've got a
small request
I've got shopping this year here's the
queue people say hi to the camera
don't leave stop thank you that didn't
take that long five minutes Aldi just
delivered the food for the neighbors and
not comfortable because of the support
group we're now getting to know people
further down the street who we didn't
know before today I'm going to be making
a carrot cake should be ready to eat
after about after we've clapped this
evening so we will be in lockdown for
another three weeks yeah so you have to
stay at home for at least another three
weeks how does that make you feel
I flipped along this road for 30 years
and it's never really felt like there's
been a huge sense of community amongst
the people living on the road until
studies letter it was really really
lovely to receive it in fact it made me
feel quite emotional and since then it's
changed and started to change how I feel
about living on this road